Oh quit picking a new book for her
highly anticipated book club selection
her 1st 2018 choice is a work of fiction
described as a love story warped by
racial injustice and now only on CBS
this morning
Oprah reveals her newest book club pick
hello my CTN friends I am really
delighted to be able to be here to share
my next book club selection you know I
don't choose them very often because I'm
always looking for the book that's going
to resonate with me that I believe is
also going to resonate with lots of
other people it's the kind of thing you
want to pass on to all of your friends I
have found it after much much much
searching it's an american marriage by
thierry Jones
tre Jones and I have to tell you it is
intriguing it's a love story that also
has a huge layer of suspense and it's
also so current and so really now that I
put it down and have already passed it
on to lots of my friends and so I know
certainly believe that you're gonna love
it
an American marriage tre Jones an
American marriages tre Jones fourth
novel and it is on sale today wherever
you like to buy your books she joins us
at the table welcome Miss Jones and
congratulations let me tell you
something it's very difficult for Oprah
to find a book that she likes it takes
months and months for her to find
something and the team works on it Lee
aber works on it so when she finds it
she gets major attitude if she gives it
to you and you don't read it right away
so she was very excited about this book
but what I find interesting is that you
got the idea from seeing a couple argue
in the mall yes I was in Atlanta my
hometown and I was trying to write a
novel and once you write a novel you
know that was more timely dealing with
the issues of the day but I couldn't
find the people for the story and I went
to the mall and I saw a couple they were
obviously in love and in trouble she was
beautifully dressed cashmere coat the
whole nine he looked fine
she looked wonderful said he had scuffed
shoes yes she's just but she was so put
together he just looked like he had had
a long day and perhaps even a long life
even though they're the same age what
did you hear that made you think there's
a book there
she said Roy you know you wouldn't have
waited on me for seven years
hmm and I was intrigued because I didn't
know Roy but I felt fairly confident
that he wouldn't wait on her for seven
years but he said what are you talking
about this wouldn't have happened to you
in the first place and the idea was born
and so the story is about this couple
that you saw but in your book their true
lives are turned upside down because Roy
is sent to prison for a crime that he
didn't commit yes and they're only
married 18 months as she says she says I
was a newlywed
I was still combing rice from my hair
yeah and he is given a lengthy sentence
that's over ten times the time they've
been married but they are married and so
the question is can this marriage
survive in this and even if this
marriage doesn't survive can this
relationship survive then can this man
survive and and and not to spoil it but
it comes out of this argument it's just
a regular old couples argument that they
have and then it ripples out why was it
the the what you saw at the Lenox Mall
that decided to put it inside of an
argument or were you just this is what
real people do and this is real people's
problems this these kind of arguments
well for me when I see two people
arguing and they seem to both have a
legitimate point
then I know I have a novel because for
me a novel cannot have a clear person
who's right or wrong
and I could see both their sides of it
and I had already I had taken a
fellowship at Harvard at the Radcliffe
Institute to research wrongful
incarceration but I had the problem but
not the people yeah you know I was
always told by my mentor he said write
about people and their problems don't
write about problems and their people
whoa and so at your Harvard fellowship
what did you learn about American
prisons and what's going on right now
you know I learned really you know
horrifying things like America
incarcerate some more of his citizens
than any other developed country
Louisiana has the largest prison
population in the world I
all these really shocking statistics but
I was shocked I was outraged but
statistics did not inspire me as a
novelist it's people that inspire me
yeah I love there's one line in the book
that caught my eye you said Roy caught
her breath with a kiss that tasted like
desire streaked with anger that doesn't
seem like a good place to be in I feel
like you know he's been imprisoned in so
much of his dreams he's hung on this
Mary it's interesting to see how this
turns out but I want to know when Oprah
first called you because you pick up the
phone and it's Oprah on the line I was
driving my car I thought it was Glee
Hebert calling me from his magazines
editor yeah sometimes I review for the
magazine I thought she needed me to
pinch-hit something you know last-minute
that's why she was calling me so late
and I was like hey and it was Oprah
coming through my car stereo and I live
in Las Vegas and I pulled over I pulled
over I had to get I couldn't continue to
drive and I pulled over on a dark road
and it was Oprah Winfrey talking to me
and I'm trying to talk to her and people
are like tapping on my window asking me
do I have a quarter to a half dollar and
I'm showing them away and I'm trying to
talk to Oprah but it was the most
exciting thing that's ever happened to
me in my life I know she was very
excited that to pick this book she likes
it very very much obviously because
you're picked and I can't wait to see
people's reaction can beautifully done
really really really beautifully done
it's called an American marriage very
nicely done
you can visit cBS This Morning Calm for
an excerpt of an American marriage plus
find a readers guide and Oprah's Book
Club content that we'll post over the
coming week over the coming weeks and
don't miss Oprah's interview with Tahari
Jones in the March issue of O The Oprah
Magazine hope you're a subscriber